In my book,
ideal,
right away with a meeting of meaning
because I knew I would be attacked like
a disturbed nest of Hornets by
philosophers if I did not.
And of course meeting has a number of
meanings,
but generally speaking,
after you've gone past the basic
religious definition of meaning,
which is,
well,
of course the divine creator,
uh,
is responsible for the design,
then a nature of humanity.
And what else do you want to know?
Uh,
after you get past that particular
response?
Uh,
then the subject moved to meaning as
history.
That is essentially what are we and why,
where do we come from?
And this is part of meetings who were,
are we was most likely to be headed.
And I like to suggest that in order to
answer those questions,
we cannot do it with religion because
every religion has or ever religious
faith rather has a different creation
story.
Story of how the universe and earth and
people came into being.
And every faith has its own special
accounts of supernatural events and they
differ one from the other and they are
in competition.
And in any case,
they,
uh,
cannot be boiled down to any kind of a
coherent explanation because religious
face is very much a product of human
culture and we can't really figure out
just what we are,
what our meaning is by introspection.
I'm reminded of the statements of Darwin
made in one of his notebooks,
which was a,
that the mind consciousness cannot be,
uh,
taken by direct assault.
We cannot imagine what we are inside my
thinking about it alone.
And,
um,
it can't,
it hasn't been really dented very well
by philosophy.
I like to see that most of the
philosophy which is a declining and
highly endangered academic species,
a incidentally a consist of failed
models of how the brain works.
So students going into philosophy,
shorter half to learn what they cart
thought and then after a long while,
while that's wrong,
and what a schopenhauer might have
thought and what might've thought or did
sink,
but they cannot go on from that position
in historical examination of the nature
of humanity to what it really is and how
we might define it.
So by default,
the explanation of meaning of humanity
falls to science and we are making
progress if I might speak for science,
uh,
and it's from five disciplines and I
will take just a moment to tell you what
they are and then it'll make sense as to
why not all of sciences whole by any
means,
which is developing exponentially and in
the creation of knowledge faster and
faster,
uh,
but from a particular set of disciplines
within science,
and I'm going to name them as I
approached that.
And I'll say you cannot,
you cannot get the answer from
astrophysics.
There are astrophysicists.
Glad to try to explain to you a
rhetorically in some way or other that
what's the meaning of humanity is and
what their studies of astrophysics tells
us about the significance of humanity.
Forget it.
They can't possibly tell you,
nor just astronomers,
nor just chemists,
nor just,
um,
well,
my own colleagues,
molecular biologists,
they're too far removed from the subject
to make any sensible thing about the
meaning of human existence.
Well,
what are the disciplines?
And if you look at these disciplines as
I've done,
and I've actually worked as a
researcher,
a in a couple,
you have to know what the contributions
are of evolutionary biology that is
biology scene in a historical context
going all the way back,
millions of years to the origin of the
human species.
And then,
uh,
another one,
another science,
of course,
it's paleontology,
which segues as we come closer to a
modern humanity and the invention of
agriculture and the birth of the
Neolithic period turns into archaeology,
archaeology,
and paleontology which are on different
timescales,
is the other discipline,
another second discipline,
and a third of course.
And everybody would know about this now
because it's progressing so rapidly in
so many ways,
is bringing science and then coming out
of brain science or running parallel to
it and trading with it.
And depending upon it and deriving from
it,
uh,
is we turned down to a more technology
savvy.
And that is a artificial intelligence.
And with a artificial intelligence is
the fifth robotics.
Robotics is so important as Hollywood is
now glommed onto knowing a good story
when they see one robotics included,
of course the notion of studying the
mind in perfecting artificial
intelligence and more than that,
creating what the artificial
intelligence and robotics people call
whole brain emulation that is using
robots as avatars and creating robots
that are designed by design and
imitation of what we know about the
brain more and more like humans.
All those five disciplines to get
together,
making bridges here and there are
beginning to tell us what's the meaning
of humanity is a product of a grand epic
and it's a full story of humanity and
we're just beginning to just draw it in
clarity and a,
let me just add to that why I'm leaving
out.
History of the whole human species
should kinetic as well as cultural.
Uh,
you have no chance whatsoever in
defining the meaning of human existence
because
history that goes back essentially to
the origin of literacy history makes no
sense without prehistory.
That is to say,
uh,
the biological evolution says lead up to
the human condition as the beginning of
history and prehistory in turn is a
study of our ancestors going right back
into the animal kingdom,
makes no sense without biology.
So we have to have a constant building,
a concatenation of ideas and
information,
discipline to discipline across scales
of the totality of the human population
and scales of time going back actually
millions of years to our early prehuman
ancestors and then forward to the era of
cultural evolution.
And then we will have the story of
humanity and then we will not ask in a
quizzical manner what is the meaning of
life?
What is the meaning of human existence?
We will have our answers.